apparently Donald Trump has a new best
friend you know not long ago Donald
Trump was telling us how horrible Mitt
Romney was he ran an awful campaign in
2012 he was no good
you know boring he failed what a loser
right well now that Mitt Romney's
officially announced that he's running
for Senate in the state of Utah Donald
Trump came out and fully endorsed him on
Twitter Donald Trump's tweet says an MIT
Romney has announced he is running for
the Senate or the Senate from the
wonderful state of Utah he will make a
great senator and worthy successor to at
Orrin Hatch and has my full support and
endorsement to which Mitt Romney replied
there Thank You mr. president for the
support I hope that over the course the
campaign I also earned the support and
endorsement of the people of Utah
interesting right I mean Donald Trump
and Mitt Romney best friends really
what's interesting is that not that long
ago Mitt Romney said that if Donald
Trump had been speaking and openly
embracing the kind of white nationalism
that he has since becoming president and
during the campaign he never would have
accepted his endorsement for president
back in 2012
there's also Donald Trump saying that
Mitt Romney had come to him begging like
a dog for his endorsement all those
years ago so suddenly these two men
super best friends right Romney's
running for Senate to replace Orrin
Hatch who overstayed his welcome a long
time ago and so MIT Romney needs that
endorsement or at least he thinks he
does somebody probably needs to tell
Mitt Romney what's happened to all of
the other candidates that Donald Trump
has endorsed and maybe Romney I'll say
oh wait a minute never mind on the
endorsement there but nonetheless these
two men engaged in this bitter feud for
so long Mitt Romney spoke out against
Trump's racism and said he never would
accept an endorsement from somebody like
that and then a few months later
literally turns around and accepts an
indoor
from that guy Mitt Romney's proven that
he has no scruples he doesn't care he
just wants to win Donald Trump believes
that his endorsement is the magical
Midas touch of American politics and
understands and even though I still
think he hates Mitt Romney deep down he
understands what's gonna happen if
Romney loses that Senate seat
Republicans are hanging onto the Senate
by a thread right now and things aren't
looking so good for them in the 2018
midterms and so if they lose another
seat if that seat that was held by Orrin
Hatch does not remain red oh oh it could
be 25th amendment time it could be you
know conviction time in the Senate if
impeachment hearings go forward in the
house if Democrats take control of that
Donald Trump is so desperate to keep
that Republican majority in the United
States Senate that he's willing to
endorse a man who one had previously
told him I don't accept your endorsement
but now I do and two says came crawling
to him begging like a dog for his
endorsement there's far more at play
than a lot of the pieces on this have
talked about Romney's taken a lot of
heat on Twitter people are making fun of
him and rightfully so let's not forget
why this is happening because it's not
just that Romney accepted the
endorsement it's that the endorsement
happened and it only happened because
Donald Trump sees the writing on the
wall and he knows that his political
career is 100% dependent upon keeping a
Republican majority in the United States
Senate we have to take a quick break
we'll be right back